hills kristen
brian a long line is now starting to
form here at the centennial center
location off tropical parkway in the
northwest
valley people are lining up to get
inside and cast their ballot tonight
despite the line here people are telling
me it's only taking about 10
or 15 minutes to get inside this
location was actually
the most popular early voting location
in clark county
rough nearly 27 thousand people cast a
ballot here
in october now i'm also being told that
it's
running fairly smoothly there are 26
election workers inside
and 40 voting machines one man i spoke
with say he waited until the last day
because that's just his tradition why
did you want to come on
november 3rd i just
always voted on election day i just
thought it was easier and
i don't really trust the process unless
i do it
metro police were called out to this
site about an hour ago there was an
issue with some people campaigning on
this site because this is private
property
i'm told though that the issue was
resolved very smoothly
and that there haven't been any issues
today
no issues with the machines or anyone
seeming to come here
to vote now again this voting location
is open until 7. well you need to get in
line by seven to
cast your vote and if you have that mail
ballot you can also come here or
to one of the 125 locations around the
valley
to drop off your mail ballot we'll be
reporting on this location throughout
the evening
and give you the latest updates
reporting live in the northwest valley
kristen drummond 8 news now